مستمرين معكم في تفاعلكم كمان في متابعه
القصه المعجزه للنجاه اربعه اطفال
كولومبيين الاطفال اللي تاهوا في غابه
اربعين يوم من بعد ما تحطمت الطائره اللي
كانوا فيها مع والدتهم وقريبهم وماتت
والدتهم والطيار والشخص الثالث وبقي هم
الارباعتين في الغابه اربعين يوم كامله
الاخت الكبرى اللي عمرها 13 سنه ينظر لها
انها البطله في القصه فهي حمت وانتبهت على
اخوانها اللي اعمارهم تسعه وخمسه وسنه
واحده فقط وحاليا الاطفال الاربعه في
مستشفى في العاصمه
بيتلقوا الرعايه الطبيه اللازمه بسبب طبعا
سوء التغذيه والحاله الهزيله اللي لقيوهم
فيها مع انه طبعا معجزه اصلا انهم طلعوا
بلا اصابات حقيقيه من غابات الامازون
الكثيفه اللي مليانه حيوانات خطيره
ومفترسه واللي كمان موطن ملاجئ عصابات
خطيره امس كنا تناولنا تفاصيل كيف كانوا
بياكلوا ايش يشربوا خلال توهانهم في
الغابه وابو طفلين منهم وزوجه الست
الراحله قال انه ليزلي قالت انه امهم كانت
وتحط يدها على او تحط يدها على فم اختها
الصغيره خوفا كانت خايفه يكونوا عصابات
ويؤذوها هي واخوانها وكشف الجد كمان
الكلام اللي قالوه الاولاد عن ويلسن كلب
الانقاذ المفقود واللي كان جزء من عمليات
البحث عنهم
وين
عندها
كلب انقاذ استخدم في البحث عن الاولاد
وقالت الفرق انه اختفى هو داخل الغابه
ايام اختفى داخل الغابه ايام ورجع خرج لهم
وبعدها دخل ثاني للغابه ومن يومها ما رجع
الاطفال كشفوا اول مره لقيهم وفضل مرافقهم
ايام وفضل حولهم يعني وبعدها تركهم يبدو
احاول يروح يجيب الانقاذ الاولاد لكن ما
يعرف يوصل لهم ثاني واللافت انه الاولاد
في المستشفى حاليا مو ناسيين ويلسن
وجالسين يرسموه
اجدد المزداول في القصه كمان هي صور
للاطفال الاربعه من المستشفى وهم خلاص
بداوا يتعافوا شويه شويه السلطات قالت
حيبقوا في المستشفى من اسبوع لاسبوعين على
الاقل علشان يتطمنوا على حالتهم تماما
بعدها راح يبقوا مع السلطات في دار رعايه
لغايه الاتفاق على الوصايه عليهم بين زوج
الام الراحله واللي هو ابو اثنين منهم
وبين الجد والجده اللي اتضح انه في خلافات
بينهم وبين زوج بنتهم
[موسيقى]